votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
et mais nelson mes frères sur la tête de
20 jeux tilt a tenu on devait le prof
d'histoire mon sérieux je pense je
prends ça comme un jeu grâce et son
micro nelson sur la tête de ma mère on
dirait que tu vas jouer devant bart
debie et vous venez nous voir d'abord
avant tout pour le mondial 2 la veste un
bien sur les i je suis bien sûr on a du
cachemire au delà du million nice on a
bien sûr de lakota juste avant regardez
alors ici des surpiqûres on les avait
pas sur la saison 2013 sur la saison
2014 elles sont magnifiques
merci l'état des sites et la main mais
c'est plutôt une jeune sabrina je
connais la marque
ça c'est le vieux campeur ça arthur ou
baba où cyril hanouna
si tu dit arthur je te défonce la gueule
à la fin je vais dire arthur tiens
mokhtar surnommé la bête vous avez
raison mais les deux ils sont si con la
clôture
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce qu'on attendait bon bah c'est
pas bien évidemment vous pouvez pas
valérie benaïm ou enora malagré les deux
en même temps c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avait bien un prénom à consonance
britannique
[Musique]
il a su retrouver
vous savez que c'est laurent luyat alors
qu'ils qui veut proposer on va laisser
les gens lui proposer c'est lui qui a la
meilleure élocution
merci la chouette
êtes vous oui ou non nelson monfort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le rideau s'ouvre
nelson elle est dans ce spectacle on
puisse parler de rideau du nom de la
star sensés laquelle tu les appelles
l'orage ça parmi d'autres à l'orage je
vais faire la version courte parce que
dure 4 minutes 40 est sûr que faire
l'ouvragé en 35 secondes prochain déjà
[Applaudissements]
heureusement qu'on s'aime bien on
m'avait caché la présence de laurence
pour ça qu'on m'avait caché là toujours
sur france télévisions philippe ou pas
toujours va la semaine prochaine je pars
avec nelson aux championnats du monde
auxquels on s'entendait bien avec nelson
mais ça va on s'entend bien on vient
nous voir la semaine prochaine je crois
voulais lui dire un petit truc ben
nelson ne raconte pas trop de conneries
parce que
on doit faire de l'audimat vous n'avez
pas un truc sur nelson monfort qu'on
sait pas qu'on pourra lui sortir la
semaine prochaine vous savez pas vous
savez tout sur nelson on n'y a pas une
petite anecdote je sais pas il connaît
bien des blagues de demander 10 kilos
raconte une
alors moi del sol allez on écoute et on
aimerait parler - de la pluie et non pas
du beau temps beau temps me dégoûte me
fait grincer des dents le bel azur me
met en vain je garde les grands bonheurs
qui me fuit donner sur terre je le dois
au mauvais temps jol d'oise et jupiter
il me tomba d'un ciel d'orage et par un
soir d'automne ramda gueule il a pas
fini
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais arrêter là
non maintenant on était dans la bouche
de garde et tonnerre de brest avec
décrypte putois à lui ses feux
d'artifice bon excellent de sa couche en
chemise de nuit
ma voisine affolé va frapper en
réclamant mes bons offices
nikon et l'on retient tulipes à fond de
vous vous avez un petit truc si vous
êtes hyper sympathique mais il ya tout
juste un petit truc c'est que vous êtes
proche de vous sous tout le monde le dit
à chaque fois on a vu par exemple dans
time à me débarrasser de ça en fait j'ai
fait une fois c'est mon choix en disant
l'émission s'appelait je suis radin et
je les assume
ouais et alors j'ai pas radin je voulais
vraiment radars ou pas juste un sportif
qui fait gaffe à c'est une parce qu'un
jour ou l'autre ça va s'arrêter ou s'ils
s'arrêtent jamais et où n'arrêtait pas
de faire des spectacles
j'ai de la chance c'est que ça continue
on va passer mois 50 euros j'étais pas
là
[Rires]
mais je tenais pas mais tu m'invites au
resto ou alors elles sont ils passent
mais tu m'invites voilà [ __ ] c'est
mon parc avec cbre au maire si c'est bon
match à cadeaux merci